on the committee's recommendations and
what's next for former president Trump
we're joined by Robert Costa our chief
election and campaign correspondent Bob
good morning okay so we know that the
panel recommended the doj investigate
Trump on four possible criminal charges
what does that mean for his run in 2024
or even his political future good to be
with you Nate it's creating a new sense
of vulnerability around the Trump 2024
campaign he got in a few weeks ago and a
lot of Republicans have been waiting and
watching to see where this all goes and
now with a possible Federal indictment
on the horizon they're wondering maybe
should they start to get in a lot of
names in the more traditional wing of
the Republican party and conservative
Rivals believe they might have a shot at
that Republican nomination should they
jump in early next year
yeah but he's still following up on that
though Bob he still seems to be very
popular among the Republicans I'm
wondering how popular do you really
think he is and how much of a battle
would it be if some of his critics like
Liz Cheney and others got in the race
how tough would it be for them it's a
great Point Gail there is a lot of
support when I'm out there on the
campaign Trail covering the former
president but some of them talk about
him in almost a grandfatherly way they
see him as someone who they like a lot
but they're not necessarily ready to
throw all their support behind him and
remember there are so many variables out
there right now Beyond what's going on
with his investigation on January 6.
just think about what's happening later
today on Capitol Hill we're going to
potentially learn a lot you remember
that phrase from the Watergate
investigation All the President's Men
follow the money we might now learn more
about six years of former president
Trump's tax returns the house Ways and
Means Committee will meet this afternoon
and decide whether to release six years
of information on the former president's
finances that's a big development it's a
big development Bob and you remember you
bring up Watergate it was Richard Nixon
who released his tax returns created
that tradition and said the American
people have a right to know whether
their president is a crook well I'm not
a crook famous line we'll find out some
more hopefully all right A lot of people
wanting to see the tax returns thank you
very much